maintenant ce que je voudrais souligner
auprès de vous c'est que même si les
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas
elles évoluent à un niveau qui n'est pas
compatible avec les objectifs de
finances publiques du gouvernement
je me réfère au dernier programme de
stabilité
les objectifs du gouvernement c'est de
réduire le déficit public à moins de 3%
à 29 en 2027 c'est de réduire ou de
stabiliser mais de réduire un peu les
prélèvements obligatoires et le
gouvernement en conclu sur un objectif
de dépense qui a été affiché par Bruno
Le Maire et qui figure dans les
documents il ne faut pas que les
dépenses publiques dans leur globalité
augmentent de plus de 0,6% par an un
réel or les dépenses de retraite même si
elle ne dérape pas vis-à-vis du PIB
augmente de 1,8% en réel et les dépenses
de retraite c'est 25% des dépenses
publiques or il est quasiment impossible
d'avoir 0,6 sur 100 dès lors que l'on a
un 8 sur 25 d'accord ou formuler
autrement si on a un 8 sur 25% c'est à
dire sur les retraites ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudra avoir une politique
extrêmement restrictive sur les autres
domaines de la dépense publique la
défense l'éducation la santé la justice
la police enfin je veux pas vous
énumérer tous les domaines de de la
dépense publique